one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
Gary Gary Gary
it's great to see you I can't believe
it's been another month
and we're going to talk about TV 3.0
let's fire it up yeah so I'm excited
about this topic and before we get our
guests let's say hi to Bobby Ann let's
say hi to Stephanie B on Facebook Solar
Surfer Z on YouTube let me see if I can
get a LinkedIn here one let's see are we
streaming on LinkedIn I'm trying to see
a LinkedIn comment oh it should be yeah
I'm not sure I don't see one yet but
usually they pound it but nonetheless uh
thank you everybody Jerome great to see
you thank everybody for uh joining
we're going to mix it up and we're going
to bring on one of our experts in in all
things TV 3.0 it's our Hugh scallen he's
VP head of video activation and Gary
it's funny I I've been working with you
for so long but I haven't really looked
at his bio oh my God he's done so many
things and he just got back from
advertising week where he got a bunch of
different insights and things so and he
happens to be one of my dearest friends
because we both were like hanging out
here a little bit so that might pop up
but I'll let you guys jump in
all right real pleasure yes usually we
go from the outside and we we will do
that but obviously Hugh you've been on
this journey with us here at Vayner
um on this TV 3.0 thing and I thought we
could set the tone for a lot of the uh
listeners here on the platforms what's
you know how do you define TV 3.0 from a
TV advertising standpoint since that's a
big uh big expertise of yours
yeah Gary thank you and we talked about
this last week sort of brought this out
at advertising week from stealth mode TV
3.0 what is it it's the TV that we know
and love it's the TV that's becoming
more digital with every day and for a
lot of people it's social media because
for a lot of people in different
platforms that's their form of
Television if you watch a tremendous
amount of tick tock or YouTube go down
the list uh it's really the fusion of
where we are and what's in action where
it's going
cue for a lot of people that are
watching here and I'm looking at the
names Sarah great to see you Chris Z
Adam M on Facebook
um this TV 3.0 the rokus the hulus you
actually rattled off 15 names of
platforms Pluto's like I just want to
set everybody because I have a big
coming keep going
yeah yeah I mean some of the way that I
break it down and try to put this in a
slide it's like your own Loom Escape
right you have the the brand name
streamers HBO Max Netflix uh Disney plus
now has ads go you go to Hulu you go to
Pluto you go to tube you have your fast
channels your avat channels uh
Crunchyroll crackle you have the whole
Smart TV industrial complex right LG
Samsung Vizio you have Amazon
um we have all the local TV stations in
America are racing to build their own
video products uh the old CBS all access
you can get CBS channels on your Apple
Plus
um we there are devices you have your
dongles and sticks your apple plus uh
Your Fire Sticks it's really a diaspora
um and it's already takes a loomiscape
to pull it together but that's a hard
way to do a plan so you have to have
kind of a decoder ring to break this all
down
in that decoder ring and the opportunity
and back to its social
let me make a let me ask a question
that I think is going to inspire a lot
of smbs and creators on this call and
then we'll get into Fortune 500 land
because their whole world our clients
you this whole world is upside down now
because it's always been EV commercials
which don't exist in the value exchange
anymore given this connective TV and
streaming Ott
is it true that now because of this
whole new universe that normal people
local businesses yeah one a single
Creator a solopreneur my dad's wine shop
one's for you in New Jersey are now
going to be able to run TV commercials
in this new environment because it's
more biddable and it's more you put in
the content and Technology like is that
true
a thousand percent I think it's uh one
of the most interesting for how low of a
for how low of monies can someone here
see
a commercial they make for themselves or
their business show up in between a show
on TV three
Hulu has Hulu ad manager if you download
it on your phone and you get approved as
an SMB as little as 500 minimum campaign
you can be on TV right so hardy D just
said okay totally lost later Hardy the
reason for entrepreneurs and individuals
listening here is for five hundred
dollars you can have a commercial for
yourself your profile your startup your
local business in between like a real
show on Hulu that's unheard of it was
millions of dollars this is a big
[ __ ] deal
what do we have like a thousand to three
thousand is the number total brands on
television as we know TV nationally and
what do we have like a million
businesses on Google and Facebook so we
could have tens of thousands
I apologize to the advertisers on
streaming TV
I apologize to you Danny Ram asked me
can I beat box so let me just do this
real quick
sorry just needed to do that I mean
really what does this mean we got three
more minutes what would this mean for
the big guys you know cool for the
entrepreneurs 500 bucks holy crap but
what does it mean for the big guys yeah
for the big guys look and we see this
every day there's really a dichotomy
there's two things on one hand if you're
big on linear television you've got to
think about linear TV reach extension so
it's effectively a math problem how do
you replace the eyeballs that are
dropping as linear ratings fall and how
do you get them back in streaming in a
world of constrained Supply a and then B
and what's fascinating kind of where you
were going earlier for marketers that
have been heavily in digital and believe
in outcomes and building brand and
social you can now bring your digital
campaign a big marketer maybe a big
marketer and portfolio has a small
budget that brand that was only in
Social only in search only in YouTube
they can now compliment they can be on
television Coast to Coast like the
friends that's right I mean somebody
just gave their I gotta set you up you
know where I'm at on all this uh final
thoughts on two minutes like
how scared are people with this
technology shift and who are the
potential winners and who are the
potential losers if they don't act
I would say to us about scare but about
confused right I mean it's it's very
complex it's hard to figure out it takes
a coalition of Partners
um you may need an extra third party
research partner you may need to hire
more influencers you may need to produce
more creative how do I keep the
frequency down right so it's it's kind
of a confusing time not unlike 10 years
ago in the rise of social
um I think the losers would be the
people who don't act if you step back
and just keep your same plan two spots a
year the consumers are moving faster
than the brands uh the media companies
are moving faster than the brands
they're creating these streaming
profiles I mean platforms globally uh so
you've got to lean in and you've got to
go back and so I think the winners are
the people that do test and learn
there's no reason like you were showing
your product earlier you couldn't
partner up if you're a cpg partner up
with Walmart connect and Roku and test
the sell-through of shoppable TV
Commerce just something we talked about
at advertising week there's never been
more opportunities to test TV because of
the fact that it's got more of an IP
basis now
Hugh thank you so much and say two
things what this shows about these
little 10-minute hits is and I see all
the comments go Google how do I run 500
ads on Hulu enter
what you and I are doing is creating the
awareness the high level strategic
opportunity for a lot of people it's
literally Google go follow it up right
now you can really get in the game and
then yes for the dozens I've seen so far
we're always hiring in vaynerx so please
go to vaynerchuk.com and find those jobs
across the board Hugh thank you brother
keep up the good Warriors here
thank you Gary I can't believe that we
have Ben Silverman coming up
Hollywood's family is addicted to the
office I was telling Ben that we went
off on a family vacation to the beach
and the family all my kids wanted to
just watch the office the office the
office he's the entrepreneur and
Visionary behind that and so much more
welcome Ben thank you so much for having
me guys and I was impressed with you
he's got I mean God you guys got some
smart gray hairs in the building I
thought it was all like we've aged up
since you and I did planet of the apps
my friend we're grown up over here now
Mom yeah that was an impressive hire
over there I'd like to see you
but listen you were a real you know a
real man of the industry on the creative
side
um why don't you actually give people
because I think people get a real kick
out of it give people a one minute a one
you're a humble dude but let's give you
a minute to do some hype on uh your
career and things you're involved in and
then I'll get into my stuff please you
know serially looking for the best ideas
wherever they were or are you know when
I lived in London I found Who Wants To
Be A Millionaire Big Brother Survivor
brought all those to the United States
and kind of it's my fault could be the
title of my biography about reality
television and then migrated into
creating our own content here in the US
and adapting others created The Biggest
Loser created a show called the tutors
historical epic which I loved
um produced and packaged up the office
you know found Steve Carell to be the
lead Greg Daniels to be the the head
writer show running partner creative
genius behind it
um always believed in Latin contact
content and latinx content is a way to
going to connect the America So Ugly
Betty Jane the Virgin two other seminal
um pieces of work in my own uh you know
resume and then uh right now doing tons
of amazing content for multiple Outlets
wife calling always good to say sorry
um and uh and everything from Chopped
which is on the Food Network number one
food show in the world hopefully all
you're watching chopped and chop Jr with
your families and producing and shooting
Shaka Zulu right now in uh in Africa
with Antoine Fuqua which I'm really
excited about for showtime and Paramount
plus and just continually making you
know premium high-end content for all
all platforms one minute or less
the chairman of NBC and Universal media
and I had the great privilege of putting
garyvee uh as we were the first wave in
Salvo into Apple's content Wars it's not
always good to be first and it's not
always good to be here I wish we were
second on that I'd be either
I know I'm so annoyed it's so annoying
brother what what are the production
companies the creatives who are trying
to fill all these pipes the hulus the
peacocks the you know HBO Max like how
is the land you know educate people here
a little bit under the hood of Hollywood
TV 3.0 will talk a lot about from the
marketing and AD side but on the
creative side is this a windfall because
there's so many more buyers uh get a
little nerdy with us Netflix has so much
leverage that they killed the back end
for a while because they had the
leverage go a little 201 301 there's a
lot of smart people here what changed
for the people inventing the shows and
making the shows with this explosion of
these over-the-top services and new CTV
environments what's different than when
you were making decisions at NBC and
there was three or four or five players
to this vaster uh Evolution or even the
incumbents having to play in the
streaming over their cable stuff like
what's the delay of the land what's
everyone buzzing about in Hollywood our
offensive part defensive right you know
if these companies coming together to
Launch
new offerings take advantage of what
technology is enabled which is a direct
to Consumer relationship and dynamic in
a way in which they can feed their
content over the Internet directly into
your home has opened up all these new
opportunities all of which are being
embraced by the studio Network oligopoly
that has run Hollywood content as we
know it over the last 50 years
unfortunately or fortunately they also
need to hold on to their old businesses
where serious amounts of money were
being generated where those are as a
cable network your relationship to an
MSO or cable provider like Charter or
comcast or DirecTV who's paying you per
subscriber for every single person
watching
um their platform whether that's a e
history Discovery
etc those were major major cash flow
machines but now as you go into
streaming in the direct consumer you're
creating a little bit of a fight with
your with your MSO with your with your
cable provider with your uh with your
satellite company so that's like one
example another great example you know
of this kind of offensive defense
another one is hey we're HBO Max we own
Warner Brothers arguably the greatest
movie studio in the history of movie
studios we make big budget amazing
movies we make Oscar running movies you
know what we're gonna do we're gonna
debut them all on TV and that got Jason
sklar collar killer kalar killed you
know and and and shot in the back of his
head as he messed with the Hollywood
show because virtually by the way
everyone yeah yeah like in in a Showbiz
sense you know because he messed with
the A-list and the A-list fights back as
we as we've seen in the Oscars and other
places and So within that context you
know he he cut off his nose despite his
face because he gave up all of this
lucrative cash on cash uh you know
Revenue that comes through his
exhibitors in the case that might be an
example similar to our show being the
first thing on Apple music not on Apple
TV one can argue that in 12 15 years
we'll look back and say ah he was a hair
early because now the scale is there
digitally I liked what you said about
you know um test and learn unfortunately
we tested we were tested and we learned
but we you know we didn't get the the
chilling dollar benefit that we all
believed in and was frankly would have
manifested had had we been able to play
that yeah distribution for sure and it's
similar for him right like today there's
still too much money to give up in
theater but as things evolve and who the
heck knows what the world looks like in
12 years with VR and this that and the
other thing I think people look back and
be like ah he was a decade early that
business move might have worked better
in today's environment as we see often
and it happens all the time like I when
I started looking at different genres of
content like I'll just talk about one
genre I gotta assume you're watching my
Untold documentaries on Netflix
um they're monsters they're monsters
right so they go you know the girlfriend
who didn't exist the the
um Mateo doc which is amazing I only
consume docs for the most part and so
like the second Teo you know all that
stuff because you know I'm a sports head
like all that stuff was phenomenal and
so in that context right here's here's
some information that that's public and
this is just an example I apologize Ben
real quick Mega loot asks is this real
live or a rerun Mega loot I'm proving
that this is live go ahead Ben live live
live live live it's it's 20 20 21. no no
it's live live in 22. so um one of one
of the things about documentaries always
love documentaries but they were
homework they lived on public
broadcasting and there were things that
would be shown in your classroom they
weren't really you know for a wide
audience and they certainly weren't
about making money right there were
elements in documentaries where you
would literally to get you would make
three documentaries over your career and
you were considered like a high output
High generating documentarian and most
of the money you raise came from your
dentist and your uncle the stock broker
and you had a rich cousin and that's how
you raise the money to make your little
docs boom arriving of arrival of Netflix
arrival of apple or you know the
maturation of Sundance and these film
festivals and suddenly documentaries are
becoming a compelling
um part of the content rest menu and if
you look at it really in statistical
level right Netflix arrives on the scene
let's say they have 40 million
subscribers around 10 percent of those
subscribers four million people are
watching a documentary when they hired
their head of documentaries now there's
over 230 million people watching Netflix
or whatever the exact number is and 80
of them are watching a documentary so
it's not just about how we communicate
or where we communicate or where the
audience is seeing the content but it's
also this opportunity to expand the
genres of content that are being
produced and focus based on and for the
price of of 10 documentaries is still 10
percent the price of the gray man or one
giant you know movie
um action adventure movie yet they can
deliver as much cultural currency and
conversation as any movie so so I mean
long-winded way to say it's like this
genre mix is suddenly exploding and
they're great opportunities for
creatives like me and people who love to
tell stories and then within the
experimentation on the streamers and the
platforms they're able to buy into more
of a of a menu of ideas and they're not
just limited to sitcom drama and games
very simple yes no answer in the last 30
seconds we have because we could do a
whole hour with you do you think there
will be consolidation of the streaming
services in the next decade it's all
about the government it's already a very
small group of companies it is a real
oligopoly and they're now the biggest
companies in the world Amazon apple com
Etc I don't know how they allow much
more consolidation and for me as an
independent I would heavily Lobby
against it of course because there's
already so few people controlling
everything you see in here
perfect
answer that phone
that was so perfect oh my God we're
getting lots of love in this chat yeah
the chat is ripping I just want to say
thank you I'm reading all of it I love a
lot of you that the comments are just so
profoundly nice
and I know you have a crazy lineup
remaining here Andrea so take them
we love you Gary thanks for joining us
all right let's bring Hugh back up on
the screen because we got more we got
more and more and more Hugh oh my gosh
was that not the best we got to get a
whole episode on Ben I think
I think you're right I mean we call it
the the vectors of TV 3.0 right there's
the point of view of Hollywood the
brands the research companies the
streamers the jumbo media companies mbcu
Smart TV World
um so many players Multicultural is
really blowing up in streaming there's a
lot of voices out there and so we try to
get everybody
but luckily you understand it all and
you're going to make it simple for us
because I'll be honest I'm I'm confused
this is helping me break it down so
let's bring up our next guest
I'm super fired up to bring up AJ
kintner who's actually kind of a friend
and a business partner in fact the last
time we saw him in the tech check he may
or may not have been out on a golf
course uh but that just shows that he's
Nimble he can do all kinds of things I
found it really interesting uh AJ that
you started your career and your
schooling in engineering and then you
decided to jump on over to the media
side so really uh fired up to hear about
your perspective and I'll let you two
get at it
thank you
yeah thanks so much you know marketing
for the now really glad to have you
thanks great to be here
you know we talk about at vaynermedia we
talk so much about as television becomes
more digital and as digital marketing
characteristics and content comes into
television and opens up so much
optionality for all the players but you
can't get there unless you start
connecting the dots with Partners like
LG ads and the whole Smart TV
infrastructure
um I want to hear all about that but
would love to hear more about your
background how you got to LG ads and
what brought you to this part of the
industry
yeah for sure I engineering was kind of
one of the things I fell into and then I
started interviewing it and in the back
pass I ran into startups and kind of
caught the bugs so ever since then you
know starting at a small startup that
went public and then was the number one
losing IPO of 2000 which is a pretty
crazy stat we beat pets.com a company
called
and then a couple years later got bought
by Microsoft for six billion dollars so
like the rides of startup have always
been something that's so fun and
actually LG is kind of a startup in the
space overall is I was in the
programmatic world uh running dsps and
more technical side of of it and then we
started to see CTV start to come into
play and so data all these types of
uh additional targeting is really where
we're heading and so pivoted over to LG
just because Samsung was doing really
well Vizio was in the market going
public it's just such a fast growing
market and covid literally changed TV
viewing in three months and that's what
we're still recovering from I think
everyone had thought we would have six
seven years to do a slow switch over
from linear to CTV and covid changed
everything
it really it really almost overnight
turned you know streaming on its head
and and like you said it created so much
viewership and so much change in the
marketplace uh when when we did some of
the prep calls you brought up something
that was really interesting I hadn't
seen this data before and in the unique
position that LG sits within the
landscape Smart TVs TV operating systems
you were talking about screencasting and
the percentage of viewing that you're
seeing that people Americans love to sit
back on the couch and watch a big
beautiful television set and you were
talking tell us more about screencasting
well the interesting thing is a YouTube
TV from your mobile to your device we
see a huge amount of screencasting for
that so you either sit down or even my
kids do this they'll be watching
Minecraft and they'll just throw it on
the TV instead of watching it on their
iPad or something so we've seen a huge
increase of just not YouTube but every
app that Simplicity of having your phone
you know choosing whatever your show and
then I love watching people do this
but we see a lot of it across the board
so you'll go back to what garyvee was
talking about of Hulu just having 500
you know YouTube in that sense has the
same amount of inventory in a little bit
different but it's on the big screen so
you know not just Hulu you can go to
YouTube and do a lot of the same type of
targeting
that's true and you can also Now on LG
sets you can not only watch your YouTube
app it's a pro tip everybody should put
the YouTube app on their television you
can watch that in Vivo you can put tick
tock on your television
is that right and you can put nfts on an
LG set is that accurate yeah the the
tick tock app went live a couple months
ago
um so it's a whole new experience of
like how it works and we're still trying
to figure out how it's used and but the
blur over of social into large CVS yeah
I talked to a lot of influencer
platforms all the time and we basically
are trying to explain the TV is an
extension of social in some degree so I
think a lot of it hasn't caught on yet
but that is the same idea of why can't
you put it you know on a big TV as well
as you're doing across instead or
whatever it is
now we speak about linear TV advertising
one of the stalwarts of Television
advertising is the pharmaceutical space
I have some background in healthcare
marketing a lot of that is a 60-second
television commercial and you were
telling me that Pharma is exploring
streaming at scale and looking to kind
of move into the streaming landscape
yeah I think overall it was the Meltdown
of linear end of the broadcast year
people are placing dollars and a lot of
it had to be shifted out of linear just
because they couldn't fulfill a lot of
what they used to be able to so we've
seen a lot of the oems and um you know
HDMI companies like Roku and Amazon
capitalize on the ability to actually
Target people uh better inside of CTV
but also just be able to deliver the
Impressions that they need to so it's
been a big shift mostly just because
linear has changed I mean what they used
to put money in there it was safe and
sound and it ran just isn't the same as
it used to be
now it's really interesting when a
category makes a pivot right and makes a
shift in their video strategy and we've
talked about TV becoming more digital
digital characteristics moving over but
it it won't make sense unless you can
prove that it works we've all heard this
in meetings before right
um tell us a little bit more about ACR
data and what that is and how in the and
you have a smart TV TV operating system
landscape that gives you a bit of an
advantage in sort of the power to know
I mean it's just the the idea of the
household having the main TV in the
household just becoming more important
to making sure that the right ads are
showing up in the right place so a lot
of the ability to see what apps or what
TV shows are coming on the linear side
just to make sure we're not over
inundating the household with you know
50 different same ads at the same time
like a lot of that is just getting
better at being able to Target the ride
at the right time you know it's just
understanding the stream of how content
is changing that's really what we're
trying to focus on is just what are
people watching more or less of you know
content-wise I'm glad you went there and
I want to give a shout out to Ben
Silverman talking about content and
maybe you guys are working on something
I don't know but LG as a system you now
have and produce some and offer some of
your own free original content to people
that buy that smart TV right
yeah the fast channels which is uh on
ours is called LG Channel plus it is
free kind of like the new version of
what cable could be it's uh it's all
free and so one of the funny things my
friend loves the surfing Channel he'll
turn it on and just watch it all day
long and so there's I almost see it in
some landscape of your passion shows you
go to YouTube or where we used to go
into social are starting to bleed over
into TV so like if you're looking for
you know surfing content you can fall
down the dark hole of YouTube but now
you can go to the TV and you can
actually choose that channel on the big
TV and just get content that's
perfectly exactly what you're looking
for for hours upon hours so I think this
idea we call it fast channels is just
going to keep growing you're going to
get more specialized content so if you
like skateboarding you like hang gliding
whatever it is again sports is kind of
what everyone's really obsessed with
right now but you know the free channels
are just becoming more and more uh Niche
with tons and tons of hours of content
which is great more of a mid-tail more
of a long tail my son would just watch
YouTube all day long surfing you know on
his YouTube app on television that's all
he watches on TV Yeah we actually have a
I think there's a meme Channel even just
the whole Channel just memes or short
clips everything you want cats we
definitely have a cat Channel too more
cat videos are out there okay
everybody's going to want to know that
in the chat
um speaking of televisions I do want to
ask you you brought up a comment when we
talked earlier about sort of the the you
know we just think about this we call it
you know modern video for modern living
rooms and you brought up an interesting
comment I love the audience to hear more
about the role of the television as a
hub of the household you know in the
homes that and apartments that we live
in
um and LG plays an interesting role
there uh for the modern living room
right
yeah I think most oems that are in the
US at least Samsung Vizio us have
started to really add apps into the OS
itself that allow uh home integration to
be a lot more seamless I mean we all see
if you buy a new TV you have a Google
Voice or Alexa integrated into it I
could turn the TV off from upstairs now
just use my Alexa so you're you're
getting more of this Hub and the thing I
always joke about is you go to the
kitchen if you're doing a remodel of
your kitchen or something one of the
most important things is where can you
see the TV so yeah especially around you
know what's going on at families where
you're watching sports or you're just
consuming content it becomes more
important that this uh TV is to get
slimmers and more integrated into the
walls like you know other
um flat tvs it just becomes easier to
keep it as part of your main room so
yeah it's basically becoming that Hub
and again the OS is flexible it has all
the new apps that are on your phone are
merging over the TV so it becomes very
seamless between mobile to TV
you know you think about the timing of
the pandemic and if you go back three or
four years
um I don't know how many CMOS we're
diving deep and you know certainly
addressable TV has been around how many
were diving deep into the smart TV
landscape what what do you say to Brands
when they're sort of faced with this
wide degree of change we're on the
precipice of a from A Brave New World
for video the way we talked about
earlier how do you advise Brands to
think about pivoting into this future
yeah your linear TV is not dead by any
means I mean nowhere 30 of our
households still have linear as our main
part of their watching ability but the
cord cutters are the other large
percentage of it so you still have to
understand that you need both together
and that's a great complement of being
able to suppress your linear partners
and then do audience extension but
really just not ignoring it just is not
the best way to do it so I think to your
point we were talking about earlier it
seems all confusing that's what we get a
lot and it it's really about uh diving
in and understanding not all of it but
you can go into one or two pieces of it
just to better understand what it means
and how you reach the audiences you want
and make sure that you're delivering the
right content to the right people I mean
it's uh you'll see more of this as
Netflix comes out with theirs because I
feel like they're very conscious about
the curation so that'll be great to see
what they do but in general I think if
you're an Advertiser you really just
have to understand
what is an oem you know how do people
consume it and how do I actually
maximize my brand across those
households
and if you're a brand that's Global
we're we're as a dawn of an age where
you know a brand other than the major
wall Gardens a global cpg brand could
run a video strategy with an oem across
multiple countries right yeah I mean we
have 130 million TDS globally you know
and Samsung's also Global Amazon's
Global these platforms are giving the
ability for one brand to reach
hundreds of millions of households
through three Partners it's mind-blowing
it's never been done before
I have to ask you then this question uh
we always get this you know three to
five years what do you think
I think you're going to have this new
idea of like uh what the cable companies
are of linear are you're going to have a
cable company a mentality for uh oems I
mean you already saw it with Roku when
you were talking about the carriage
agreements they're getting into so I
think that you're going to have both
working well together because you know
we do
um
work closely but I think you're going to
have another kind of player in the game
thank you AJ yeah thank you for having
me that was amazing thank you all right
Hugh we got Jed Meyer up next from
cantar he's worked across the entire
ecosystem from Buy sell Tech uh he's
been almost everywhere I feel like
ubiquity Google Univision OMG Nielsen
and he sits on all kinds of Industry
boards I don't know where you find the
time for all this but we're gonna find
out
Research Foundation right 100 the airf
great Partners great way to uh I always
encourage a lot of young people to get
involved with the ARF because that's how
you make connections in the industry you
build relationships and you kind of like
we work together what probably 10 years
ago now at Omnicom that's right you stay
in touch with people and you know this
business the media business is so built
on relationships and now with of course
the added element of Technology being
woven in there between all the different
new technologies that we have today that
we didn't have 10 years ago when you and
I were at Omnicom yeah 100 and for the
audience Jed and I have worked together
in the past and you know I was thinking
we've we've had sort of this TV 3.0
discussion before you know we have
linear TV we're adding online video
let's talk to our research Partners how
do we study it you were at Google we had
a similar question so sometimes the more
things change the more they stay the
same but I think today it's a little bit
different the role of Television
streaming and social video
um I think
cantar is particularly well suited to
have a strong point of view in the space
depending kind of where you sit between
all the key players I'd love to have the
audience learn a little bit more about
kind of your journey to cantar and what
draw you to research and Analytics
yeah uh thank you Hugh first of all
thank you for having me and uh I love
this space because at cantar we sit
across so many insights right about
consumers and what they're doing and
around the you know media events that in
the media that they consume and what we
try to do is knit all that together
because our clients who are everybody
from Big Publishers to advertising
agencies to Brands they just want help
right there you know I've heard this
from some of your other guests it's a
it's a fragmented industry it's ever
changing with all the technology you
know it sounds really silly to you but
sometimes my goal is just to help make
the clients a little smarter so they
have more confidence to make their
decision right you know what channels do
I want to invest in where do I put my
next dollar where are my ads performing
well how am I building my brand things
like that we try to help them understand
those kind of questions by either
talking to consumers or using
measurement devices to do that
what what are clients you know CMOS
telling you so from the brand side as
they begin to shift and we're talking
millions of dollars big companies or it
could be a big company with a small
brand if they have a tremendous amount
of digital investment and they'd like to
put their brand on television like Gary
was talking about what what are they
what are the sort of their concerns that
keeps them up at night when they think
about these changes that they have to
react to because the consumer is moving
with us or without us exactly you know
you know years ago when I was at Omnicom
we started the sort of trend of follow
the consumer right and you know if you
recall way back then Paige Thompson our
big boss was challenging us like how do
we move money
yeah onward and upward right how do we
how do we help our clients navigate that
change we're still doing it though like
but you say the TV 3.0 now it's not just
online video it's connected TV it's
social video it's all these new
platforms you know whether it be snap or
Tick Tock and so a lot of the CMOS when
they when we talk with them they want to
know what do I use when right and I want
to build my brand and I want to be
present in digital it's it's much easier
to make the sale about digital today
because the whole world is digital and
back then we were still kind of
persuading people you know to take that
tiptoe into the sort of online video
world now it's like which channels work
for me and how do I build my brand
and then how do I prove the impact right
to my CFO to my CEO to my other
stakeholders in the organization
um and it's hard right with all this
fragmentation and with getting consumers
to cooperate and with the walled Gardens
and how do you knit all that together my
perspective is that companies like can't
darn it's not a sales pitch it's just
reality we're a third party right we're
neutral and so I think companies like
cantar and other third-party research
companies are critical right to helping
Brands and Publishers decide where to
move money and where to invest because
we don't have a dog in the race right
when I worked at a big Tech platform my
job was to prove the value of that
inventory and I love doing it because
it's a big platform and it's called out
earlier and they're great at reaching
people but now you know people shouldn't
just spend their money on one platform
they should spend it across others AJ
your last guest talked about that yeah
it wasn't just promoting LG ads he's
saying you gotta buy an ecosystem and we
try to help people do that
let's let's do double click a little bit
more into that the sort of the how part
if you're if you're working with an LG
uh we heard from Ben and Gary earlier
he's going to have a show on NBC it's
going to be on Hulu you know his Clips
are going to be on Snap On Tick Tock how
do you help Brands Stitch those things
together uh you don't have to get too
wonky on us about it but um you're able
to sort of tell how the campaign works
and then how you're building brand over
the top of that for the Long Haul no
exactly so so we've been doing that you
know I like the business I looked after
as the brand lift insights business
right so that's really looking at what
campaigns work and what channels do they
work and that started years ago when it
was a company called Dynamic logic just
measuring internet you know computers
versus laptops and then it evolved into
Mobile and then it evolved into
connected TV and then it evolved we
measure out of home we measure the
packing tape that some companies put on
their boxes to promote their programming
and to promote
yeah you know and but here's the thing
the ads are everywhere right so clients
want to understand our premise is simple
sort of a control and expose and measure
the lift that those you know consumers
notice oh I noticed you're promoting a
football game on Thursday night and then
you know do they take action on that and
stuff and we can we can try to you know
measure that so that's the sort of big
picture of sort of what we want to do
and help our clients understand again
the channels and the impact of it the
next level of that you well sort of the
first level is how do we do that across
platforms including the walled Gardens
and we partner with the Googles and The
Meadows and the Amazon to help do that
and then to help Stitch it together for
the agency and The Advertiser who want
to look they're not just buying one
channel they're buying multiple channels
right so that's a really important value
add that we provide and then sort of
where it's going you is what other
action did they take right did they make
a purchase was there footfall into the
store you know did they did they visit
the quick service restaurant what do
they do after they saw the ad and that's
you know for the non-wonks on the call
that's what we call in lower funnel
activity and that's really where people
are really curious about what happens
next
you know pushing a step further on that
we we have the pipes the data and the
technology to do things on TV we happen
before we've talked to a lot of clients
about so-called brand formants or
performance TV we was an advertising
week last week there were over 70 panels
almost 15 percent of the total content
was on this whole TV 3.0 subject out of
500 panels one of them that I was on
with Roku and Walmart connect was about
shoppable TV or e-commerce or vcommerce
what what's a declines ask you about
wait a minute you're saying I can use
streaming TV to sell a product directly
and you can interact with QR codes or
with remote controls
um dogs and cats living together I mean
sort of Brave New World is this the
thing that clients are aware of they're
able to kind of use
CTV for performance purposes
yeah look you know starting with the top
of that one right here the the brand
performance thing the idea of mixing
brand and performance is fascinating to
me you know I I thought I understood
digital and then I went and worked at
Google and I was like wow the the amount
of data that they capture in the mid and
the lower funnel stuff is amazing but
you still have to create awareness of
your brand you still have to cut through
the Clutter and that upper funnel you
know sort of awareness metric is still
super important if you're trying to you
know break through and and launch
something new and and you know create
consumer awareness right so brand is
still super important I love the mid and
lower funnel measurement the other piece
you're sort of talking about is that
whole growth of retail media networks
and connecting that to CTV that's why
it's so fun to work in this space right
here it's like it's changing all the
time you know last week they announced
the potential Kroger Albertsons merger
and you're like wow the amount of data
that that company sits on right you know
premium placement targeting and then
also first party data on purchases
that's it's a an advertiser's dream
right it's like wow you know pulling all
that together so it's really a lot of
fun I want to say thank you for inviting
me and I love this whole series and uh
really appreciate the opportunity to
share with you and your audience
yeah you know Jed we were talking about
University of Wisconsin earlier I talked
to undergrads all the time and I told
Andrea this there's never been a more
exciting time to be in this business
right
adaptability what one plug for your alma
mater you mentioned the area after the
start of the show uh your Alma Mato
supports the ARF wide initiative which
is a diversity initiative to help make
the industry look less like you and me
we need to support ARF wide we
appreciate UW supporting that and uh and
go Badgers
to conclude this thanks so much
thank you Judd
all right Hugh we're going to give you
just a bit of a rest so you can you can
catch your breath and we're going to
welcome up our beloved Chris Anthony
from Gallery Media Group
thanks you thank you
hey Chris oh office life
I love it we got the white board right
behind you we're gonna fire up a bunch
of ideas I can feel it
all right I think Nevada got to turn his
his sound on
oh fantastic there that's much better we
can hear you we can hear you
Chris I'm super fired up about this next
uh conversation that's going to be with
under armours Demetria georgiev
um and he's got 20 years of experience
across all kinds of Interest Industries
including Sports and Retail and
financial services uh and what I found
really fascinating is just the fact that
it used to be an athlete and a fan and
now he's finally gotten to join his
favorite brand
so I'll leave it up to you guys can't
wait to listen in awesome thanks Andrea
hi Dimitri how are you hey Chris good to
see you how are you good to see you as
well I'm good excited to chat and all
things TV 3.0 with you likewise likewise
awesome let's get into it um obviously
Andre gave your great sort of bio and
the work you're doing in Under Armor
which excited to talk about today and
sort of your thought leadership on on
this space with all the great
conversations we've had today
um talk a little bit just about this
evolution of TV and video and sort of
all these words that are becoming fluid
um with the evolution that's happening
and how does Under Armor you know really
macro think about this change
yeah so I I'd start by saying that Under
Armor is a storytelling brand right you
know to us that's authentic to our DNA
um we love athletes right that's our
mission that's our that's that's the
core of who we are to make athletes
better and so when we think about TV
it's not just about a TV plan or a
digital plan it's about a video strategy
holistically and so for us it becomes
really about using that Medium to tell
stories that really connect our brand
our athletes to the Everyday Athlete and
inspires them to be their best so
um it is about a holistic video strategy
not so much uh just about a TV strategy
per se
love that talk a little bit more when
you talk about that Everyday Athlete
with this whole Evolution from connect
to TV Ott just you know all these
platforms that are sort of really
democratizing this space that really
allows you I think to think about
different types of consumers and
customers that Under Armor a little bit
more in specificity talk a little bit
about that like from that standpoint
yeah I mean I think like linear TV has
always been this wide wide reaching you
know you want to reach the masses you
want to try to get to them where they
are uh most engage in leaning in great
right but when you think about uh CTV
and the the digitization of basically TV
you have the ability to go reach Target
audiences and be more personalized and
so for us that becomes a great Advantage
right because we want to go reach
Runners we want to go Reach team sport
athletes and and so for us to be able to
actually go find find them through the
medium that we think is most impactful
uh through video right is is a big
Advantage so I think I think the
evolution of the TV space particularly
um CTV gives us an ability to go get
that younger audience go go reach the
runner go reach a team sport athlete
um and those are just a few examples of
of audiences but I think in general the
idea is that the medium really does
gives you it gives you an advantage
where you can be very very deliberate
about your approach
you mentioned you know athletes
obviously quite a bit you being a former
one obviously that's sort of like the
core in the DNA of Under Armor how do
you think about leveraging some of that
talent and sort of like the amazing
roster that you guys have curated over
the years
um and kind of creating a fabric to some
of the Partnerships you've done talk a
little bit about that um and maybe some
examples that would be interesting to
kind of share
sure sure
um we've had we've had a lot of great
stuff that I think um you know what
we've realized over the years I've been
in Under Armor now for about three and a
half years and
our mantra's really been we need to
activate our athletes we need to think
about how our how our roster and how the
partners that we work with that really
are are big fans of the brand we're big
fans of theirs like how do we bring them
to the Forefront right and so there are
a couple of couple examples I can share
that I think are great uses of of Art
and Science right how do you take the
medium of video and make it more
impactful the first one is
um when Steph Curry broke his uh broke
the three-point record right is a big
milestone in the history of sports right
well we we we thought hey like we knew
that was gonna happen right like we're
in tune with our athletes the whole
world knew that was going to happen so
we actually developed a film right a
60-second film we worked with Turner
they actually were great Partners in and
when the when the record-breaking moment
happened the commentator actually said
and now this special moment from Under
Armor and then it broke into a 60 second
film like this wasn't an advertising
moment this was a great moment it's a
moment in history and and we got to be a
part of that and obviously Steph gets
all the credit and he's he's amazing and
he's you know an amazing partner to work
with but at the end of the day it was it
was Art and Science coming together and
really thinking about how do we actually
put our athletes and athletes at the
Forefront of our storytelling and doing
a way it's created it's going to connect
with the consumer rather than just doing
advertising and I think that's that's
the key
um a key formula that I think most
brands should consider is how do you
make it more about the art and not just
about advertising
love that and we talk a lot about just
like the the reason and sort of the need
for relevance with Brands and there
couldn't be a better example of like
that coming together so such an amazing
example congrats on that front yeah
Chris and I I have another one for you
that I think is really good is yeah so
right now I mean um again like we think
about our athletes right well we have
Tom Brady on our roster and he's been an
Under Armor athlete and partner of ours
for a very long time and so we knew that
hey like this was the end of The
Season's like the end of his career is
happening right
um and the the Mantra of like who's
going to be the next Tom Brady became
very clear to us that like that's the
that's the storyline right is it Lamar
Jackson is it pat Mahomes is it like you
know Alan like who is it right and then
and then came out this sort of campaign
of like be the athlete that no one saw
coming and so we use tv as a platform to
have Tom Brady Morgan Freeman come
together and have this campaign and
launch it during Tom's first game like
during the season right as as bucks on a
Sunday night had a Sunday night Prime
Time game and so another example of
taking our athletes taking relevance and
this cultural moment and making it
making it make sense for the time not
just like forcing your stories on the
consumer
love that too such amazing examples talk
a little bit about
um you know the technology in this space
is obviously moving so quickly right how
do you feel like as marketers are
catching up to it and even consumers
talk a little bit about that of just you
know how to kind of stay abreast of all
the constant change and sort of be able
to do amazing examples like you're doing
um to the audience
yeah well I I think we were chatting
before and I gave an example of like I I
you know before I came to Under Armor I
was working at Capital One and financial
services and I remember uh about 20
years ago you know 15 20 years ago we
launched the very first mobile app right
mobile banking app which at the time was
like wow this is cool like what are apps
and like you know apps
on there is very limited right but I
think it ultimately revolutionized like
the way you bank right and and we were
the first ones to watch that and at the
time we thought hey there's not going to
be Bank branches anytime soon right
there's no way there's going to be Bank
branches like that that's going to be
done in 10 years well I don't know if
you've driven up the street like you'll
find a bank branch everywhere and so I
think if you think about
TV and video and the and the evolution
of digital right like it's moving really
fast but at the same time there's
infrastructure there's process there's
outdated things that still kind of are
here so as as marketers right we have to
figure out how to create our own
ecosystem for our brand that works based
on what what the what the art is to go
along with the science and so you know
I'm all in on CTV and streaming and and
how do we use you know the the rest of
the digital video landscape but then
realizing that like linear is still here
it's still really important when it
comes to live sports and that's at the
core of very much of what what we do
um and so so yeah it's about navigating
it all but one of the examples I use
often is that you could you could
graduate from your MBA program and
digital marketing and then next day it's
outdated like you you you have to
constantly be learning and so I think I
think that's why all of us have to be
um have to bring our a game and be
constantly educating ourselves
love that that totally makes sense and
it's so so true talk a little bit about
you know we talk about about social
video and sort of tick tockification
it's happening in the internet from you
know highlights and short form video how
do you think about that fitting into
sort of this TV 3.0 strategy and sort of
equal leather the same uh different use
case talked about how like social video
fits into this
yeah I mean I think obviously Tick Tock
has done a great job of of capturing
eyeballs right I think the younger
consumer and we do a lot of media
consumption
um studies and understanding of who are
who our target audience is we think
about the younger consumer they're
ultimately like they're not going to sit
there and watch a game for three hours
but they're very in tune with what's
happening during that game or they might
watch the game in the background for
three hours but then they're also going
to be on their phone doing a million
things so we we do think about that and
we understand that you know they're
still very into sport it's just that
they're probably more into it from a
highlights perspective staying in tune
being culturally
um on top of things and so social is is
a perfect
compliment to TV right you if you have
um if you have that that like big Big
Brand storytelling you need to also
accompany that with quick hit uh quick
form what you capture in 13 you know
three seconds six seconds 15 seconds Max
in Social right and also not be afraid
to be a little organic and authentic and
not so curated when it comes to some of
the content so I think having a balance
uh having that balance for a brand is
really important uh and not being afraid
to understand the nuances between the
channels and you know we do a lot of
work with Google and meta and we bring
them to the table and say hey teach us
about what's going on your platform like
we we know we're good at Brand
storytelling how do we go beyond that
right and so I think
um I think that's a big part of our our
Evolution yeah I love it all totally
totally interesting and I'll totally
make sense last question most important
one what are you watching right now what
should we be watching
even new baby at home
so I I I I gave an example about Tom
Brady but we had man in the arena on
ESPN plus something we we sort of uh we
were a title sponsor for it was a really
cool marketing opportunity but that was
a great history of of him and where he's
at
um in his career and just the journey uh
so that was that was a good one but I
think like welcome to wrexham just
watching the buying a club trying to
have it go up in the rankings in the
Premier League I mean that I I it's for
me it couldn't be better and then I grew
up during the Dream Team error both the
dream teams and
um I just the redeemed team
um again all sports related and and
rightfully so uh being being a sports
fan and and at UA but I think the
redeemed team is just a great example
it's so patriotic and seeing the pride
of our country and and how we how how
Sports matters it's matters in community
right and I think that's also the reason
reason why video matters and video
storytelling matters because you can
Inspire and ignite a community in such a
positive way through Sport and video is
a really big important way to do that
yeah that's all totally true I feel like
there's many things that are not
unifying but Sports can be one of them
for sure love that
um so many great examples and such a
great conversation thank you so much
Demetria
thanks to you both pleasure to meet you
guys thanks for having me
thank you Chris
all right last but not least let's bring
up Gabby Fenton
she's the head of latam for vaynermedia
and so much more I love this girl
oh good and we're lucky to have Leslie
Koch of Televisa Univision who I just
met at a brand week conference on enough
to break bread with her as well she's
such an expert in engaging the U.S
Hispanic consumers across platforms and
really fired up to to hear a little bit
more about how you guys can break it
down
thank you I'm so excited
hi Leslie hi Gabby is that a cause
sculpture you have it is a cough oh I
love that it is a cost that was super
fun super fun I have one here in my
office and another one at home awesome
it's good to be back to the office I've
got to start decorating oh I can help
next time I'm in New York I'll go to
your office and help oh thank you how
you been I haven't seen you in two days
everything is going well we are back in
the office so I am enjoying catching up
with colleagues and and having that
energy so it's really good awesome okay
so listen Leslie you have you have quite
a story and quite a career so so let's
see if we can grab your brain for 10
minutes
sure listen
um I I'm super Keen about this theme so
maybe you can enlighten me okay so I
have a question for you I actually have
four let's see if we can go through the
four okay Hispanic market drives
businesses it's a fact okay that's a
fact and I'm very passionate about it my
my boss is not as happy but I'm super
fast so I want to ask you a question why
is this relevant for Brands today
especially why is this relevant for GNC
because you've been studying these uh
like for a while so so tell us a little
bit about that sure so every brand wants
to grow that's a basic fact of marketing
so if you want to grow your audience and
you want to grow your Revenue you need
to find an opportunity or a tap a new
market so you really can't grow your
brand without the Hispanic market in the
US so
um if you I just got this stat this week
so this is very interesting if the U.S
Hispanic Community we're a country
we would have the fifth largest GDP in
the world so higher than Great Britain
so there's massive spending power there
and then also if you look at gen Z in
particular a hundred percent of the
growth in the Gen Z population is driven
by the Hispanic market so you have more
Hispanics uh net growth coming into the
youth Market than leaving it so it's
really an important audience that you
need to tap if you want to grow your
brand
can you tell me a little bit more about
the Cultura matters because I was
reading your your deck and it I think
it's absolutely amazing by the way but
the Cultura matters why why are there do
they feel that culture when it's
embedded between the things it's so
important for them
sure so the Hispanic Community is a
young Community but even for Latinos
born in the U.S Spanish language is a
really important cultural signifier so
we've done a lot of research we have an
amazing research team here and they've
really shown that U.S Hispanics even the
youngest generation really have a
preference for Brands communicating to
them in culture recognizing their
Hispanic culture and traditions
communicating with them in Spanish and
it really shows they're being
acknowledged for their Heritage so
that's something really important so at
Televisa Univision we produce content
that we call it in culture in language
so it could be in Spanish it could be
bilingual but it's always culturally
relevant so it's something that's really
striking that chord with our audience
and they they actually the audience
really reacts to that they drive higher
engagement with that content
and they they buy through so so I'm
gonna like like into how much they're
buying through television it's not about
social but but through television you
were talking to me last week about how
you're interviewing uh from television
to the several ecosystem like how tell
me more about that sure so we're really
a 360 company so television we have our
linear presence and our audience is
actually
um really we're really retaining the
audience the Hispanic audience more than
other networks which is great but we
always have digital social streaming
um as part of that approach and live
events as well so I'll never forget
um my first big event last year was
going to the premios juventud awards in
Miami the Youth Awards so for us it's
really important to always have these
multiple touch points we really are
aware the consumer is and this year we
launched vix which is our Global
streaming service and it's actually the
first large-scale Spanish language
streaming service in the world worlds so
I think we're really placing emphasis on
how all these different platforms
complement each other and how we're
reaching a consumer across all these
touch points
that's very big in Mexico by the way oh
great there's some amazing Televisa
content in Mexico I know I know it's
very big so um Leslie what's your take
in in the evolution of TV how I would
ask you how can marketeers strike a plan
to position brands for what's next
because this is like there's something
coming next
I honestly I think it's been where the
consumers are and adjusting your
messaging
um to the audience into the platform so
having a specialty I head up our social
advertising team here at Televisa
Univision
um it's highly targeted so we're able to
reach people in really specific
categories
um so I think it's really important to
understand your audience invest in tools
for example we have insights tools where
we can profile Spanish language social
media users and find out what topics
they're interested in which of our
properties they're more interested in we
also analyze this sentiment of their
comments on our campaign posts so really
understanding the consumer is so
important because that same consumer is
on all of these platforms they really
play together so you don't have only TV
it's not a totally separate audience
it's social you really have to consider
them being kind of in a different state
of mind or different um situation when
they're using each platform but it's the
same person
the same person yes he said you know
because you know it we are very media
live and breathe and truly believe truly
believe all of us that friends are
building social and we we do this
through storytelling that it's something
that you're very passionate about
storytelling throughout your career it
has been very relevant um this business
Council tell us more tell us more about
storytelling please so we're so I had
the advantage I started out in Market
Research that was my first media job I
was a research assistant at timing so I
wrote questionnaires for people in
Espanol and team people
um conducted focus groups I think that
was a really good foundation in data and
it really taught me to understand
um the audience and what makes them tick
and how they're reacting to content and
then transform that into strategy so
that's been the Common Thread through my
career
um when I was at HBO we developed social
insights to use for programming and
marketing at Turner we used our data
basically to launch our Global advice
products and here at Televisa universion
I am really excited because we're very
Innovative so
um I have a team that not only activates
campaigns on social but they pull
pre-sale insights as well so they're
basically from the initiation of the
campaign they're identifying the
audience for the brand the Spanish
language audience what makes them tick
they use that to inform their activation
and targeting strategy and then they
handle all the reporting as well so it's
really an exciting opportunity to take
that data and bring it to life and act
on it which I think is pretty unique to
social
it is unique and I I love that you smile
when you tell me about it you're really
really passionate about that
inspiring and listen any tips what do
you what should Brands be focusing on by
for 2023 uh what are they missing what
do you feel if if you could recommend
something from your from where you're
sitting what would be your takes on that
is there anything you could recommend
our clients
definitely I'd say Commerce is key
um and commerce we were talking about
different platforms it's cross-platform
Commerce so what can we do on connected
TV on streaming on linear on digital on
social so that's something that I'm
definitely working through with the team
um social also Hispanics are 25 spending
25 percent more time on social networks
and they're also 43 more likely to click
on an ad in a social feed so for me
finding that right um formula of how to
drive brand awareness and consideration
in Upper funnel metrics and then convert
those users to purchase using social
digital and on air that's really key for
next year we need to have attribution
and we need to have a really developed
product in general as media companies
that really bring consumers down that
funnel
can you buy go back a little bit to that
data it's 43 more than the General
market that they click and buy
so Hispanics are 43 more likely to click
on an ad that's in social media than
non-hispanics so that's why I'm not a
millionaire
what's in 16 you work I'm working I've
done really well but that's why so
that's why well I would say the U.S
Hispanic market these are very Savvy
consumers
um and over over index on a number of
different categories so in a way as a
Hispanic marketer and someone in the ad
Community it's kind of an easy sell
because our Market is so engaged with
different ad categories so between that
and me working at vaynermedia I'm doomed
for good
thank you Gary and thank you thank you
because I'm doing I'm guessing not be a
millionaire ever
uh Leslie uh you speak Spanish tell me
tell me tell me something in Spanish to
say goodbye to this team okay
um
you should definitely follow her on
social media thank you so much Gabby I
love it I love it
thank you very much oh my God
that was fantastic thanks for bringing
down all those statistics it's uh it's
just eye-opening right for a lot of
people really important stuff love to
you both thank you thank you Andra love
you thanks for wrapping up the show
all right we got another show coming up
on November 16th from 12 to 1 p.m
Eastern so we hope you guys will all
come back please join and register let
us know what you thought about this show
and if there are other things that you
want to learn about the the chat was
super hot today and we were we're
combing through we're listening we're
listening
um but check us out on our website
mftn.vaynerx.com thank you and see you
soon